in terms of the testing a hundred
thousand a day would be very welcome how
are we gonna get to that point where it
does seem we we have been pretty slow at
this point well we've hit the targets
that we set at the start in terms of
testing but we clearly need to ramp up
the amount of testing
so yesterday I set the goal of a hundred
thousand tests a day by the end of this
month and we have a plan with five
pillars to deliver on those in the first
instance the tests that are being done
by public health England and within the
NHS those tests which are the bulk of
the tests at the moment they need to
expand but more than that we need to
bring companies private organizations at
the universities all to bring their
testing capabilities to bear on this you
know Britain didn't go into this crisis
with a big testing industry a big
Diagnostics industry but we have got a
world-beating pharmaceutical industry
companies like Astra Zeneca
GlaxoSmithKline and so they're going to
turn some of their industrial might to
this question of testing and we're going
to be working with the existing testing
companies to really ramp up their effort
it's a it's a big task it's a big ask
but you know you we're opening the NHS
nightengale today we managed to build
that in nine days on ventilators we
asked companies that haven't ever made a
ventilator before to step up to the
plate and they're delivering ventilators
and now we need to do the same on
testing yeah look I don't want to sound
overly negative because I know a lot of
people are putting in an awful lot of
work at the moment and obviously people
are trying their best but you say it's a
big ask and a big task well people are
offering to help out and we spoke
yesterday to a director for our genomics
and accredited fertility testing Center
they say they can handle 800 swabs a day
they have apparently been trying to get
hold of you or people in your team for
three weeks and still haven't had a
response why is it that in there
number of cases I've heard something
similar from ventilator companies why is
it that people are struggling to get
through to offer services that they're
willing to give well clearly with the
existing program we've been using the
big labs but this is a national effort
and everyone's got a part to play and if
those tests work and it's really
important that they work because I've
also had lots of offers of people from
tests where when we've gone into the
details of it the test hasn't worked it
is a complicated piece of biochemistry
one of these tests so long as they work
then we want to work with them so we're
I'm expanding my team on this all of the
time and all of those companies all of
the the labs that can play a part in
this national effort and then we want
them to why is it though that we do seem
to be behind other countries in the
state of of testing I know people talk
about Germany a lot I know they've got
in some respects better resources when
it comes to this sort of area I know
there's issues with reagents but the the
w-h-o said test tests and tests and yet
Jenny Harris the deputy chief medical
officer said that an advice at the time
didn't apply to us have we changed our
position on that have we been a bit a
bit the reason that that comment was
aimed at others is because we've been
ramping up our testing all the time a
month ago we only had the capacity to
test 2,000 people a day it's now 10,000
but I've as you know I've set the goal
nationally of hitting a hundred thousand
by the end of the month now it's true
that some other countries like Germany
went into this crisis with a very big
Diagnostics industry Germany has over a
hundred labs that were that we're ready
to go if you like and we've we started
with some of the best scientific labs in
the world particularly Portland down a
very famous world-class lab also Colin
Dale some of the university labs and
but there but not the sort of scale that
Germany had if you look at other similar
countries that start in a same sort of
place like France we've tested for more
people than in France so if you look
internationally there are examples where
they started in a stronger place there's
examples where like us they've been
having to build up from a much smaller
base all that matters to me is getting
this right and getting the the British
national effort on testing up to up to
the scale it needs to be in the same way
that we're expanding the NHS and making
sure that there's always the ventilator
capacity that people need for this very
specific illness so you know we of
course we look internationally to learn
from what's what we can from abroad but
all that really matters is delivering
for the nation and not in the whole
country
coming together to try to solve this
great problem of coronavirus one of the
big problems of course is to do with
staffing in the NHS at the moment and
hopefully testing will obviously
eliminate some of those issues we know
and when it comes to frontline staff
we've had some some high-profile cases
of people who have sadly died as a
result of this where are we in terms of
frontline staff who are critically ill
well they it's true that and the the
testing for frontline staff is a really
important part of what we need testing
for as of yesterday morning five
thousand frontline staff had had been
tested it's also important that we have
tests for the families of critical staff
so that they don't have to isolate if
one of their family becomes ill so they
can get to work and and as of yesterday
that's being rolled out - and the that
you know forgive me for interrupting me
for interrupting but where are we on
where are we on the numbers here because
actually the number
are critical you must be aware of the
numbers because of the direct impact
it's having on frontline services yes
exactly I was just about to come onto
that so the the the number of doctors
who are off is five point seven percent
so it's just Minh to get that number
down but it's much smaller than some of
the numbers that have been bandied about
and in the main the vast majority of
people in the NHS are are doing their
duty and going into work and you know
speaking directly to them I know how
hard this is within the NHS and I think
they've done an absolutely amazing job
of stepping up to the plate and and
doing their duty and and the vocation to
care for people I think is just
incredibly inspiring to us all those
there's there's no question is there
about that and we saw that reflected in
the in the applause again last night but
look that the Royal College of
Physicians is saying a quarter of its
doctors are off sick the Royal College
of nurses are reporting a high number
two and I mean that would seem to be
higher than your five point seven
percent yes those figures are wrong and
that's why we release the figures of the
five point seven percent of doctors it's
just under 8% of all staff and which is
a much more reassuring picture and
because that's the that's the that's the
accurate picture and but of course I
want to get those figures down which is
why this staff testing is important to
where are we in PPE personal protection
equipment because obviously there are
concerns that there isn't enough of that
by a long way in the NHS at the moment
and obviously some of these infections
could have been caused by that where are
we in terms of the supply chain for PPE
well on PPE
we do have large stocks that we had in
place in
case something like this happens the
challenge is getting the right PPE to
every single person right across not
just the NHS like you mentioned but also
social care and then some of the other
critical services like prisons so that
delivery of the PPE is a tough
logistical exercise we brought the army
in to manage it and they've been
absolutely brilliant and and and I I'm
working on it incredibly hard to try to
make sure we get PPE to everybody
because yeah I understand we're asking
people to put themselves in harm's way
and we've got to make sure they've got
the right equipment now the number of
people who have are complaining to our
hotline and say we haven't got the PPE
that number is falling which is which is
good news but we need to make sure that
we get PPE to everybody the right PPE
for them to use for the for the work
that they're doing look I know you've
got a lot on this morning just two more
questions if I may before you have to go
can we talk about lockdown in isolation
and obviously were struggling to get a
precise figure on when things might
start to change that's understandable
but have you got a strategy in place as
to how we end a lockdown because it's
going to have to be phased out and
something to do with the antibody test
as well isn't it yes the the first step
is to get the rate of infection down so
that that isn't increasing and as you
say there's a it takes some time after
the lockdown is put in place to to get
that a rate of infection that's being
the transit rate of transmission down
that's the first step then we need to
make sure that we have the testing in
place and the and the tracking so that
people you know we don't if we release
any of the measures we don't simply then
have the infection spread again in the
the way that it was starting to spread
when we brought the measures into place
so it is a it is a very difficult
thing in the meantime we've got to give
that economic support to people
especially to businesses to keep jobs
open and on that I think that the
Chancellor ashisu NOC has been doing an
unbelievably good job in giving all the
support that we possibly can and he's
been lauded around the world for the
quality of the measures that he's
brought in and for the comprehensive
nature of the economic response this is
a really tough time for on the economic
front really unprecedented but there is
nobody who's been doing better job than
the chance of a tracker ashisu knack in
making that happen look you've had Kovac
19 you're looking pretty well after your
a period of isolation the prime
minister's been releasing videos it's
got to be said he's looking pretty rough
he's clearly not not been faring as well
as you have under all of this well I
think he got it a little bit after me
and it you know it in my case it it is
rough especially when you're on the
downhill part of it it's very worrying
because you know we've all we've all
seen how serious it can get I had a
couple of days when it was really very
unpleasant and I've lost about half a
stone but thankfully I've then have them
recovered and I'm now feeling I'm now
feeling fine and it's very good to be
back at work and I've talked to the
prime minister all the way through this
he's working very hard as much as he can
from home obviously in Downing Street
and but I've worked with him every day
all the way through and he's he's doing
what's needed and taking the decisions
but and we all wish him a very speedy
recovery the Secretary of State we
appreciate your time this morning thank
you very much indeed